this image combining line art and a
photo was saved as a JPEG and it looks
fine on a phone at small display sizes
but on a desktop monitor resizing the
browser window the JPEG format begins to
show its weaknesses with JPEG edges can
lead to artifacts for this example SVG
for the logo would have scaled better
here's the same with SVG for the logo
over a JPEG of the photograph the photo
and the logo both look good small or
large and see those crisp edges they're
both look great file sizes are down too
here's the version with the logo over
the image as a one single jpg and here
we have the version with the SVG over
the JPEG and you can see that even they
win an extra file request we're actually
only using about half as many bytes take
a look at these three logos they look
identical right but if you check with
the dev tools you'll see that we've used
three different file formats and there's
a massive difference in file sizes the
chrome SVG there is well it's about a
twenty fifth the size of the PNG there
are some good general rules for
improving cross-platform image
performance use JPEG for photographic
images and browsers such as Chrome also
support other formats such as web p
which can deliver better compression and
features web p supports alpha
transparency animation along with lossy
and lossless compression now if you can
use SVG for vector images and we'll show
you how to do that later and for vector
art and solid color graphics such as
logo and line up if you're unable to use
SVG use PNG and do use PNG rather than
give more colors better compression and
no licensing issues for more information
about image formats take a look at the
links below the video